joel looks different in the last of us
part one it took me a while to spot the
difference but once i did it was hard to
unsee there is a pain in his eyes his
clothes and features are the same but
there's a quiet unmistakable torment
imprinted on his face i've played the
last of us nearly a dozen times across
ps3 and ps4 and i've never seen this
side of joel before i know joel has a
troubled past because the last of us
part one goes out of its way to show me
a traumatic death in the opening scene
but that pain was never etched into his
facial features this clearly
ellie
[Music]
you're treading on some
mighty thin eyes here now there's an
argument to be made that the last of us
part one is too similar to the ps3 and
ps4 version to be considered a remake
and part of me agrees with that
sentiment the story is identical the
level design is exactly the same and the
gameplay apart from some quality of life
improvements is unchanged on paper if
you've played the last of us and
remember it well there's little reason
to return to it on playstation 5. but
the last of us part 1 is more than the
sum of its parts it's an unrelenting
tour de force that strategically
leverages the power of the playstation 5
to push its story and themes a little
further slight though they may be all
these enhancements serve the story and
the story is just as good as it was 9
years ago the most obvious way the last
of us part 1 does this is with its
visuals the overhauled lighting sharp
textures and smoother animations make
the last of us a prettier game but it's
the details in the faces and characters
that make it a more meaningful one these
details may not alter the way you think
about these characters but they
certainly add more depth to them what
does recontextualize the characters is
the existence of the last of us part 2.
joel's actions are harder to stomach
knowing his eventual consequences and
ellie's bloody quest for revenge makes
her character arc in part one all the
more tragic even if you don't like the
direction the narrative took in part too
it makes the final moments of the last
of us part one even tougher to swallow
what's more interesting is that despite
knowing how things would eventually
shake out i rarely question joel's
motives throughout the game even in
those final moments it's a testament to
naughty dog's superb storytelling and
fantastic characters that despite
knowing full well what joel's actions
entailed i wanted to protect ellie at
all costs all those complicated feelings
the last of us left me with nine years
ago came back even stronger when i
wrapped up part one
what's wrong with these guys catch your
breath
we're leaving
the gameplay improvements although
subtle are also done in service of the
story aiming is more responsive weapons
have a satisfying heft to them and joel
is a bit easier to maneuver he's not as
nimble as ellie in part 2 but a lot of
the rough edges in the original have
been smoothed out this kind of stuff is
to be expected in a remaster or remake
but in the case of the last of us part
one it removes another barrier from the
experience the tweaks to the combat and
gameplay give joel a more cohesive
characterization on screen it may seem
like i'm reading a bit too much into it
but think of the times you've clumsily
missed shots because of the way the
aiming works in a sense it undermined a
character that has been fighting to
survive in a hellish post-apocalypse for
20 years he shouldn't be whiffing shots
in matters of life and death with the
tweaks joel is as ruthless as you'd
expect from someone in his position and
with his tragic history
the improved ai meanwhile brings with it
a greater sense of peril especially on
the tougher difficulties enemies are
more aggressive and employ advanced
tactics some will pressure you from afar
while others will flank you if you
aren't paying attention every now and
then an enemy will wait for you to
approach and go for an ambush the
unpredictable ai makes for some
harrowing fire fights success demands a
mixture of forethought improvisation and
skill it helps that companion ai is much
better too in the original ellie tess
and bill would frequently end up in
places they shouldn't be they couldn't
alert enemies but it was always a bit
jarring to see ellie run in front of an
infected while looking for cover
occasionally in part one a companion did
get in my way in some tighter areas but
i haven't seen anyone carelessly wander
into the fray in this new version it's a
small fix but once again it makes this
world feel more authentic where the last
of us part 1 shows its age is in its
level design just like the original 9
years ago the game often relies on
pallets dumpsters and ladders for its
traversal puzzles part 1 takes place
over the course of a year and joel never
takes the time to teach ellie to swim
this means that every time you encounter
deep water you need to find a
conveniently placed pallet to ferry her
across a small body of water it was hard
to overlook back then but it's even
harder to overlook now all right i need
you to i know
naughty dog has gone through great pains
to immerse the player in the world and
these simple puzzles don't fit the tone
of the game they are rote video game
moments in an experience that doesn't
need them the combat arenas also feel a
bit too enclosed and straightforward
there are some standouts like the docs
at the beginning of the game or the
bookstore in philadelphia but most of
the encounters take place in linear
corridors with waist-high objects used
as cover this lack of freedom limits
your options in combat and makes it
difficult to improvise when your back is
to the wall it's a shame because joel's
arsenal is varied and his craftable
items can be fun to use it's even harder
to overlook given how impressive part
2's level design was the reason why
combat felt so dynamic in part 2 was
because there was always room to
improvise and multiple avenues of
approach to support this this is
unmistakably one of those moments where
the limited scope of the remake
undermines the idea of creating a
harmony between the first and second
parts of the last of us overall story
while the narrative and characterization
certainly feels more cohesive now the
same can't always be said for how they
play however fixating on gameplay
discrepancies between both games
diminishes the last of his part 1's
achievements the brilliantly paced
narrative is supported by some of the
finest environmental storytelling in the
business so much of the world and its
inhabitants can be extracted from the
smallest details a throwaway line
between two hostile npcs can shed light
on other parts of the world while a
simple message scrawled across a wall
hints at how the outbreak was handled
two decades ago the environments are
rich with detail that add flavor to joel
and ellie's adventure
military preparatory school
yeah nice way of saying orphanage
i wonder what happened to all these kids
this place has been out for a good
stretch
they ain't kids no more
meaning they're either hunters trying to
kill us or they're dead or they got away
you don't believe that
i believe in getting out of this city
come on
the most welcome addition to the last of
us part one is its impressive suite of
accessibility features like the last of
us part two there are a wide range of
visual auditory and difficulty settings
that can significantly lower the bar to
entry and make the experience more
accommodating you can customize
subtitles tweak screen shake enable
different vision modes and retool the
controls at any time to fit your needs
even if you don't think you need any of
these features you might find something
in there to make your experience a
little smoother i frequently played with
high contrast mode enabled to help me
track down smaller collectibles that i
wouldn't normally be able to see but for
other players these newly added options
might make what was previously an
unplayable game into a playable one the
most painful omission from this remake
is factions the stellar pvp mode from
the original game the multiplayer mode
had players choose a faction and build
out a camp of survivors by running
supply raids which were matches that
pitted you against the rival faction
success would earn you resources to keep
your compound afloat naughty dog is
working on an expanded standalone
multiplayer component set in the world
of the last of us and its sequel but
it's a shame the original factions mode
didn't make the cut
[Music]
all these improvements taken by themself
may seem minor but together they make
one of the most memorable games of the
ps3 era even better in some ways the two
parts of the last of us are now better
aligned making transitioning between
them much smoother but in others the
years of progress in game design and
development are all too apparent but
while some of the level design may not
have aged all that well the vivid cast
of characters and remarkable story is
more poignant than ever
i'm sure your friend will be missing
this tonight
[Music]
light on the reading but it's got some
interesting photos
ellie that ain't for kids
whoa
how how the hell would he even walk
around with that thing get rid of that
hold your horses i want to see what all
the fuss is about
oh
why are these all stuck together
i'm just [ __ ] with you
bye-bye dude
you